The joe rogan experience.
Everybody's so like hyper aware of themselves and like they're so afraid to
laugh at fucking anything.
You know?
There's a lot of that,
but there's a lot of cool people out there too.
It's just got to figure out how to attract only them.
Well,
you have a cool audience,
dude.
I mean honestly I don't know how I pulled it off for a cooler crowd and you play
like some really cool off the wall venues and that that's,
that's what it's about.
You know,
I always hear from waitresses and it's one of the coolest things ever.
I always hear from waitresses that my people are nice and generous tippers.
I love that.
That is,
to me,
that is the ultimate compliment that somehow or another of of,
of accumulated a bunch of Nice people and understood the greatest thing that can
ever pull off.
Well they love it.
Like when your crowd are good drunks,
like my crowd.
Yeah,
master drunks.
They know what the fuck to do with the little kids.
He's the first person I saw studies stand up because of that.
It really being a the insomnia show and he caught me.
I recording him cause I didn't,
I never went to a comedy show so I didn't know like what do you like?
I was used to bands.
I'd always try to sneak my camcorder in and try to take something like a clip or
something.
So going to be $8 on stage.
The videos,
him pointing at me,
he goes,
hey you have with the camera.
I turned out
I wanted to bring that clip.
I forgot that should have brought that bloody probably was fatter and just like
all puffy.
I love that.
Like 20 pounds of booze on the puffiness.
It's really not the booze,
it's the Burger and fries and more fries.
And then of course you've got to have a piece of cake,
you know,
porn for your stomach.
Oh,
after gigs,
man,
I eat like several people.
You know,
like when I do a two show Saturday night,
Brian,
I'll tell ya,
repressive,
ridiculous amounts of food where people,
they don't even don't only think I'm being honest,
the waitress three times to honor,
give me two entrees.
I want a steak and I want a chicken.
I'll wait.
Here is always leaves.
You're like,
I'm not done.
And then yeah,
I order stupid amounts of food after gigs man.
What's your like,
what's your like fucking guilty but what's your like waffles swap after his
sheriff.
Fuck,
I love officers.
Would crazy amounts of butter on them.
Do just slather that shit and butter cover that motherfucker.
Maple Syrup and I'm not really down with those Belgium waffles.
I like the waffles they give you when you go to Roscoe's.
Roscoe's chicken and Waffles,
they have the thin waffles.
Waffles are the real deal.
Those big stupid Belgium waffles.
Those puffy fucking stupid waffles did too much show.
That's all you got.
I'll take the Belgium waffle but God dammit regular waffles or better.
What's your stays?
What's your late I was like,
well you know,
cause I was professional drunk so it'd be like a,
you know,
lots of meat I needed to me to like fight the booze and my stomach but it always
came up shitting blood and just horrible.
You know,
fucking just like how many times you shed blood.
I'd say like,
I've shipped blood for weeks.
Oh my God.
Then I've shipped,
you know,
being a crime,
like you don't have healthcare so you gotta kind of like do your own
analysis to taste it too sweet.
I do my own kind of,
maybe I need less oranges in my diet,
but a,
I'm like,
you know,
all those horrible experiences,
but I definitely meet was the thing that would help me fucking fight the booze.
But I'll tell you like now that like I don't drink,
there's something about cake that like,
it's like pussy,
you know,
it's like,
like you'll stare at it and like try not to be,
you know,
like let it know that you love it.
You know?
Do you try to eat healthy?
I'm trying to eat like a,
which we call it like oatmeal cause like old meals like this,
like when you hit 46 so they'll like,
oh,
we'll take,
you know,
we'll help you.
I was like,
nothing's going to fucking help.
I'm chain smoking,
drinking black fucking coffee here.
Like coffee's good for us.
Is it really from,
Oh man,
it's Kona coffee.
I love this shit is stopping,
drinking,
help the blood,
like he's still bleeding now.
I only bleed for the economy.
I have a job troops for Joe,
I believe for the troops and the economy.
We know jobs.
When you,
um,
you know,
you just sort of let it stop bleeding.
No,
it just,
you know,
whatever,
it's,
I don't know.
You're your to come up blood brother.
I did the same thing.
And like for me,
I,
it happens for weeks for me to
honestly,
I mean,
I'm just amazed.
I'm still alive and like the fact that like,
you know,
I'm so self destructive,
like my mother,
you know,
she's such a sweetheart,
like,
you know,
I kinda like,
we're responsible for her.
So that's like the only thing that keeps me from like,
crossing that line of like,
you know,
like fuck yeah,
I'm going to huff paint.
And you know,
I mean,
because honestly,
you know,
when you're a comic and you're out there balls deep in the road,
it's like,
do you really care?
You know,
it's like you just looking for the next fucking wild.
It's fun.
It is fun now.
It's,
yeah,
now it's fun to have a bunch of shots with some people and kind of do high five
and the problem is the next day.
Yeah.
And that's the problem.
But then now you get older,
right?
And like you got a mortgage and you've got to do,
you know,
you got kids and everything like that.
It's like,
ah,
I just wished blues didn't do any damage.
I wish booze was like weed or you did it.
You never felt the next day you're fine.
Well because we're American,
we fucking work hard and we drink hard and we and we,
and we're like,
fuck you.
We have the right to do it.
Cause your,
someone could reengineer booze.
You know,
some scientists need to get on this whole Buddhist thing and figure it out.
Give me the effects of booze,
you know,
make it tastes like booze.
But figuring out a way where it doesn't wreck your system.
There's gotta be a way to recreate being drunk without,
without making you just poisoned.
You know?
I mean really,
where we're so retarded,
we go poison each other.
It has like so many good effects for it.
But it was never my drug.
But I like,
I totally am like,
we're all like,
lot of guys don't get him our don't like it.
Rather Stan hope doesn't like it.
Yeah,
no we were boozing and like,
you know drug guys,
we weren't going to,
what was it though about the weed that you didn't like?
Well no offense,
but I thought it was kind of prissy.
I always thought it was a sit around and like there's something about weed and
like sitting on a couch and then all of a sudden there's a guitar there for some
reason and then now you're hearing a million parodies.
You're hearing a million fucking ditties and everyone's giggling and then they
even don't.
But if you're hanging around with the idiots and they get high,
you're right.
You're in for some profound stupidity.
But I think it facilitates thinking.
Definitely.
I can show you how a lot of people don't like it cause it makes you paranoid
though,
because it can,
it's if you're not into that,
if you're not in to looking at yourself,
it can fuck with you.
Well,
Dr Drew,
you know,
not to bring it up.
I love Dr. Jones.
No.
Okay.
Yeah,
the Rehab I've,
I've watched a few times just to go,
whoa.
Well,
like they had a guy on there,
I'm not going to say whatever movie star.
He was like his vaporizing pot and then like,
oh yeah.
You know what I'm talking about?
Say his name.
Eric.
Robert.
Okay.
Eric Roberts.
So I dunno if he's done the podcast or not,
but no,
I would love to have on the podcast by the code,
you know,
whatever.
Pick up my fuck dumb.
Here's the most,
uh,
he's the most celebrity to be rehabbed in my mind.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's an amazing actor.
I like,
if that's all he's doing,
so be it.
It's La,
he's an actor.
Getting high is like,
you know,
it wasn't a part of the,
I think that was just the shit career move.
It was just a terrible career move.
I mean,
come on.
He's saying that he's got an addiction to pod.
That's so just stop smoking pot.
Yeah.
Everybody's shaking their all shitting blood.
It's like reading the papers and drinking a cup of coffee.
It was like nothing was wrong with,
this is one guy that doesn't have a problem.
It's like they showed him vaporizing in this beautiful bathroom in this house.
That's not the sign of a drug addict.
That's how you should be like an a shack.
The trailer park.
It's just silly.
Yes.
Freaks and Geeks.
Lovers and children.
What's going on.